[Musique]
à la fin de 2020 le gouvernement du
québec a désigné comme art protégés de
nombreux territoires situés pour la
plupart dans le nord de la province
ces désignations ont permis à québec
d'atteindre son objectif de protéger 17%
de ses milieux naturels terrestres
c'était un engagement international mais
au passage la candidature de dizaines
d'autres zones situées dans le sud de la
province beaucoup plus près des
populations a été rejetée dans plusieurs
secteurs une précieuse biodiversité
attend donc toujours d'être protégés
[Musique]
on a commencé d'abord trouver dans nos
archives des documents qui avait été
écrit par notre a peur des gens qui ont
utilisé un territoire bien avant nous et
qui avait laissé des traces écrites
à chaque fois qu'on allait à des
endroits précis on trouvait les vieux
sentier on trouvait les vieux cible de
convaincre
et abandonner le fait une découverte qui
tout changer l'histoire
ce qu'on a trouvé une peinture depestre
de forte dimension 1 500 gares d'ici le
crew nos ancêtres à quelque part qui ont
décrit des rituels qui ont décrit de
leur mode de vie qui ont écrit bd des
choses de la vie courante
malheureusement c'est beaucoup
d'informations
louis lesage et son collègue sont des
hurons wendat la découverte il y a
quelques années de cette peinture
rupestre a été l'élément déclencheur
d'un long processus de demande pour
créer une réserve forestière protéger
cette forêt que les hurons wendat appel
yanyan en d1 située à l'ouest de la
réserve des laurentides
elle couvre une superficie de 800
kilomètres carrés dont une grande partie
est considérée intacte lorsqu'on rendre
cette foire est là c'est un peu comme si
on entrait dans un sens ou ailleurs dans
une cathédrale qui est un peu spécial
qui est unique
le professeur en foresterie louis
bélanger participent à cette mission de
conservation
cette forêt il la connaît bien
scientifiquement on utilise l'expression
forêts intactes
c'est à dire c'est une forêt qui n'a
jamais été perturbée par les humains
elle était perturbée par la nature
régulièrement l'industrie planifié pour
aller couper ce territoire là dès les
années 40
mais le hasard fait que les épidémies
arrivait juste au moment où l'industrie
forestière planifier ces coupes ce qu'il
faisait en sorte qu'ils abandonnaient le
territoire pour revenir trente quarante
ans plus tard pour avoir un corps un
synchronise avec nouvelle épidémie de
tordeuses qui rajeunit c'est la forêt il
a demandé moins intéressante pour
l'industrie
aujourd'hui ce secteur est de nouveau
visé par l'industrie forestière
c'est donc une course contre la montre
pour les hurons wendat documenté
scientifiquement la biodiversité de
cette forêt pour prouver qu'une
protection est nécessaire tout un aspect
qui demande à être inventoriés
quelles sont ces espèces l'association
forestière
comment cette formule a évolué on veut
vraiment aujourd'hui utilisé la science
aussi pour nous aider à vraiment
comprendre les décrire comme il faut
cette fois la nation a ainsi mandaté
plusieurs chercheurs pour récolter
toutes sortes de données
philippe baile doyon lui faut il les
cavités 2 les corses des arbres alors
ici devant nous on retrouve un gros
spécimens de bouleau jaune de plus de 80
cm de diamètre alors ce qui est
particulier avec les gros boulot j'en
sais qu'il change des corses quand il y
en a des grosses plaques comme ça il
s'intéresse aux lichens particulièrement
les cales ici aux ide
la présence de ce type de lichens est un
bon indicateur de l'état d'une forêt
céder tout petit dit yen qui sont
associées aux vieilles forêts est ce
qu'on appelle la continuité écologique
qui règne au territoire forestier votre
tout le temps avoir maintenu un couvert
forestier jamais été affectés par
l'aménagement l'industrie et c'est une
vieille forêt comporte des lichens mais
aussi des mousses et divers micro
organismes qui sont aussi liées à la
grande présence de bois mort en
décomposition
et bûche en décomposition souvent ces
niches un champignon parce qu'il est
riche en chair peu en vue il est
beaucoup de consommateurs d'aider des
champignons c'est le plus peur que ça
c'est des insectes
on pense que c'est probable un élève
plus d'espèces qui est ici mais lui est
ce que tu veux tchèque
l'entomologiste timothy works et son
équipe s'intéresse aux insectes présents
ici l'hypothèse est simple plus une
forêt est riche en biodiversité
plus il y as d'insectes le est ce que je
peux vous aider avec tout un arsenal de
pièges ils capturent les insectes pour
établir une comparaison entre ce secteur
forestier et d'autres forêts qui ont été
touchés par les activités humaines
il est beaucoup de sorties insectes donc
on utilise beaucoup de mes idoles du
livre contre des cinq sections des
pièges des intercepts qui pourrait
frapper des insectes qu'ils volent comme
des coléoptères pour l'éditeur qui vole
en mettent des pièges dans le canapé
pour attraper des insectes qui s'associe
avec le canadien peut être qu'il va
traquer de chimie qui habitons à cannes
puis on met des pièges faut sauter pour
capturer des organismes qui marche sur
le tapis de nos forêts
ce grand secteur forestier comporte
aussi plusieurs lacs dont le grand lac
batiscan et il y a le lac à moïse un
endroit très prisé par les pêcheurs
d'ombles de fontaine un des poissons les
plus pêcher au québec mais le secteur
compte aussi quelques lacs très
difficile d'accès où la pêche est quasi
inexistante en étant à peu près pas
pêcher c'est là qu'il nous montre des
caractéristiques innovantes des
populations naturelles pratiquement
vierge
[Musique]
le chercheur pascal sirois s'intéresse à
l'état de la population de l'omble de
fontaine avec ses étudiants il mène une
pêche sélective selon la fontaine
pour le biologiste avoir accès à des
lacs intacte permettra d'obtenir des
données unique contrairement au reste
rétorque québécois on retrouve souvent
nombre de fontaine comme espèce
compagnone avec des espèces introduites
comme l'homme vous le meunier noir
démener l'avoir des populations
dont la seule espèce et landes de
fontaine le seul territoire va nous
permettre d'aller chercher des
caractéristiques de vos places y ont
vraiment intéressant et pour lesquelles
on ne peut donner à ce jour donné un
exemple très concret on connaît très peu
l'étau mortalité naturelle celle de
fontaine donc de pouvoir les calculs et
sur une population très peu affectée par
l'être humain c'est une donnée qui peut
être intéressante et qui peut servir à
une meilleure gestion distincte sur le
territoire par la suite ses lacs
intéresse aussi la chercheuse
roxanne tremblay qui fait des recherches
paléo limnologique sur plusieurs lacs au
québec
la chercheuse analyse les diatomées ce
sont des algues microscopiques entouré
de silice on peut s'en servir pour voir
la perte l'ampleur des perturbations
donc ça peut être des pertes des
perturbations humaines ça peut être des
perturbations naturelles c'est que
l'accès la trappe
ils l'attrapent le signale finalement de
tout le bassin versant
grâce à de grands tubes elle va puiser
des sédiments au fond du lac
[Musique]
on a sorti une belle carottes de
sédiments du lac chardon donc on a les
archers de plusieurs centaines pour ne
pas dire milliers d'années du bassin
versant
alors ici on a ce qui est récent et puis
ce qui est plus ancien au fond des fois
on a des surprises parce qu'on n'était
pas là jadis ok on y arrive ce que ça va
nous apprendre c'est justement youtube
des études et grands événements que
c'est peut-être pas l'homme qui était à
l'origine de ces événements là mais ça
va peut-être avoir amené des des
changements importants
que ce soit la découverte de lichens
calissi aux ide typique de vieilles
forêts une récolte d'insectes
impressionnante
ou bien la pêche à l'omble de fontaine
après plusieurs mois de travail sur le
terrain et d'analysés en laboratoire
tous les chercheurs ont trouvé des
éléments qui confirment l'unicité de
cette forêt pour louis bélanger cette
forêt si elle est protégée pourra servir
de comparatifs scientifique un outil
utile dans un contexte où la nature subi
des changements importants
on protège quelque chose d'unique
un peu comme une cathédrale que si on la
démolit il y en aura plus et il y en
europe on aura plus pour du couple de
siècle mais également en termes de
gestion de notre environnement nos
témoins nous baromètre pour voir quel
est l'impact des changements climatiques
des changements globaux sur un
écosystème sans interférence des humains
ce qui va nous informe énormément lors
sur la réalité des phénomènes
biologiques associées aux changements
climatiques
[Musique]
les hurons wendat espère que toutes ces
recherches inciteront le gouvernement à
protéger ce territoire unique
quand on regarde une carte du sud du
québec les forêts vierges forêts
intactes ont toutes disparu celle là
c'est la dernière grosse soirée
donc si on la conserve peau on va
regarder une carte du québec
toutes ces forêts le vent avoir disparu
si peut-être on va passer à côté d'une
occasion unique d'avoir eu la chance de
préserver cette forêt le et probablement
et avec justice
nos enfants vont nous juger de ne pas
avoir rien fait pour la protéger
[Musique]